gute nachrichten für alle jürgen drews
fans er war beim friseur so sieht es
zumindest aus auf dem cover seiner
aktuellen single wenn die wunderkerzen
brennen außerdem sein neues album kommt
die tage raus schlag ab er war ja schon
mal bei pixum und zwar ganz ganz ganz am
anfang quasi ein jubiläumsgast ich bin
extrem gespannt ich hoffe ja auch und
ihr habt eine menge fragen am start die
am besten wieder als video antwort auf
dieses video postet link jetzt hier im
video oder unten ins kommentarfeld
klicken dann eben dann der link zum
upload eurer video antworten respektive
video fragen dann lasst euch wirklich
was einfallen und lässt vorher den
infotech sein kann eigentlich nichts
mehr schief gehen nicht durchgenommen